[Musique]
moi je sais pas si c'est moi ou le sac
je remette milieu en fait j'avais envie
de commencer en vous posant une question
je voulais demander à tout ce qui
concerne de l'eau en bouteille en
plastique de lever la main ouais c'est
bien ce qui me semble bon en fait
j'avais juste envie de vous culpabiliser
un petit peu puis après je vous aurais
rassurer je vous aurais dit mais vous
inquiétez pas vous n'êtes pas les seuls
5.5 milliards de bouteilles d'eau en
plastique chaque année en france sont
vendues
puis j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit
peut-être que je devrais pas vous
rassurer parce que moi j'ai pris
conscience de la rareté de l'eau lors de
mes nombreux voyages expérience de vie
que j'ai pu avoir en afrique en asie et
dans nombreux pays
j'ai vu des enfants marché 2,3 heures le
matin en pleine chaleur à plus de 40
degrés pour aller chercher quelques
litres d'eau une eau marron impropre à
la consommation
et il recommence et le soir autant dire
que chaque goutte d'eau compte
imaginez vous faire cela ne serait ce
qu'une semaine vous n'auriez plus jamais
le même regard sur l'eau l'eau devient
de plus en plus rare et pourtant on n'en
manque pas sur notre planète pas plus
que deere d'ailleurs je m'explique vue
de l'espace on voit qu'il ya plus de ces
enquêtes de terre
mais même si l'eau recouvre 72% de la
planète plus de la moitié de la
population mondiale est en situation de
pénurie d'eau proche du fameux jour zéro
le jour zéro c'est le jour où il y aura
plus aucune goutte d'eau qui sortira du
robinet les habitants du cap
l'été dernier en afrique du sud ont
évité de justesse ce fameux jour 07 et
et l'inde a vécu sa plus grande crise la
pénurie touché plusieurs régions et le
gouvernement était obligé de livrer par
train et par camion de l'eau à des
villes comme chez knight des villes de
plus de 10 millions d'habitants est là
au moment où je vous parle
dix sept pays sont en situation de
pénurie d'eau et des estimations
récentes pense que d'ici 2040 20 pays
supplémentaires seront en manque d'eau
potable
heureusement sur notre terre la terre ne
peut pas manquer d'eau et l'eau que vous
utilisez tous les jours pour manger pour
boire pour vous laver elle provient du
cycle de l'eau le cycle de l'eau il
commence par l'évaporation des mers et
des océans mais aussi sur les continents
les terres les cultures les forêts les
lacs les rivières
la chaleur va faire monter la molécule
d'eau le froid va là liquéfié elle va
tomber sous forme de de pluie ou de
neige et la quantité d'eau qu'on a sur
terre elle est constante elle s'épuise
pas contrairement au pétrole aux
minerais qui cela quand on les aura
consommé y en aura plus et les
perpétuelles
elle est là elle revient par lesquels
tant par les précipitations elle
retourne à la mer elle repart dans l'air
c'est un cycle sans fin
c'est même rassurant de savoir qu'on
aura toujours autant d'eau dans un
million d'années
donc la question c'est pas savoir quelle
quantité d'eau on a sur la planète
mais quelle quantité est potable est
accessible pour soutenir toute la ville
sur terre cette image que vous avez
derrière vous a été réalisée par des
scientifiques de l'ue et jsc édifiante
parce qu'elle vous montre tout l'eau
qu'on a sur la planète sous forme de
sphère en comparaison aux volumes de la
terre la grosse sphère bleue petite
flèche blanche
c'est l'ensemble de l'eau qu'on a sur
terre lasserre intermédiaires qui
étaient qui doit être avec une petite
flèche rouge ça c'est l'ensemble de
l'eau douce souterraine dans la majeure
partie est inaccessible parce que hors
d'atteinte
et là tout petit minuscule c'est toutes
les eaux douces de surfaces disponibles
que toute l'humanité doit se partager et
on aura une autre vision du khalife du
qualificatif la planète bleue le pire
c'est que cette petite source on
entraîne les puiser à cause de notre
surexploitation et notamment dans deux
domaines l'agriculture et l'industrie
à eux deux non seulement ils consomment
92% de cette réserve
mais en plus c'est les plus gros
pollueurs et la pollution de nos sols
aujourd'hui nous oblige à traiter de
plus en plus notre eau je dirais même on
l'a su retraite
90% des masses d'eaux superficielles
sont réputés contaminés par des micro
polluants persistants
c'est à dire 90 % de l'eau qu'on utilise
tous les jours est polluée par des polos
des micro polluants persistants
devraient parler je voudrais vous parler
maintenant d'une autre source d'eau qui
qui fait la panacée c'est l'eau minérale
en bouteille alors celle là elle nous
est présenté comme un aliment sain et
naturel que les français adorent
d'ailleurs peu ce que je voulais dix ans
consomment 5 5 milliards de bouteilles
d'eau chaque année et l'impact
environnemental est catastrophique
la fondation denmark arthur estime qu'on
a réussi que moins de 20% de du
plastique sur terre si on tient compte
du fait que pour fabriquer une bouteille
d'un demi litre
il nous faut trois litres d'eau et 33
centilitres de pétrole l'année dernière
on a brûlé 17 millions de barils de
pétrole pour fabriquer les 89 milliards
de bouteilles en plastique utilisées
dans le monde je vous rappelle que dans
un baril de pétrole il ya 5 159 litres
de pétrole les conséquences de tout ça
c'est la pollution de nos sols et nos
océans
en fait une étude allemande qui a été
publié en 2014 trouver 25000 résidus
chimiques à l'intérieur des bouteilles
en plastique
donc à la fin de cette crise
on a un peu l'impression que tout ce
qu'on fait est mauvais pour
l'environnement ça c'est un peu vrai en
tout cas tout ce qu'on produit est
mauvais pour l'environnement
et il faudrait peut-être avoir une autre
gestion de nos ressources pour résoudre
ce problème les petites décisions qu'on
va prendre au quotidien peuvent affecter
les ressources de notre planète
en fait moi ce que je peux dire c'est
que l'époque d'insouciance ont pensé que
l'eau était inépuisable est bel et bien
terminée et moi je me suis demandé de
mon côté qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire
et je me suis dit qu'on devrait
exploiter se forme formidable potentiel
qu'il ya de l'eau de l'air et pour ça je
voudrais qu'on revienne dans les années
2000 ou sur les conseils de mon épouse
que j'ai su écouter mais j'ai souvent
s'il écoute et d'ailleurs en fait j'ai
cédé mes affaires et on est venu
s'installer aux caraïbes lors septembre
2001 est une date que les américains
n'oublieront jamais et nous non plus
d'ailleurs
alors que les new yorkais vivaient ces
événements tragiques une autre psychose
est venu les hanter d'une contamination
des réserves d'eau de la ville par les
terroristes
moi j'étais assis devant ma télé et là
je me suis dit mais qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire pour avoir de l'eau dont
on est sûr sans être lié à un tuyau
quelques temps après ozap ans sur une
chaîne je regarde une émission où on
nous montre que les nous expliquer que
les incas à l'époque récupérer l'eau de
la rosée du matin sur des fils en fait
ils avaient copié les araignées qui eux
heureux enfin toutes leurs sources d'eau
elle vient de la rosée du matin elle
récupère voilà lé petit coup traite
comme ça sur leurs toiles
c'est à ce moment là que je me suis dit
mais il faut absolument qu'on puisse
exploiter ce formidable potentiel de
l'eau de l'air en reproduisant le cycle
naturel de l'eau
c'est là qu'a commencé une aventure qui
a duré près de 15
quand vous avez quelques ingénieurs on a
réussi à calculer le point de rosée à
toutes les températures et taux
d'humidité est en fait on a réussi à s
extraire de l'eau h2o la molécule d'eau
à l'intérieur de nos générateurs alors à
ce stade la molécule elle peut pas se
polluer parce qu'elle peut pas se
mélanger
en fait la molécule d'eau il faut du
temps pour se mélanger ce que ce soit
des pesticides ou que ce soit des
minéraux si vous prenez un verre d'eau
que vous mettez un sucre dedans ou du
sel vous allez voir qu'il faut du temps
pour que tout ça se dissoudre et c'est
exactement la parade la même chose avec
la molécule d'eau en fait elle
n'arrivera à se mélanger console mans en
contact avec le sol avec du temps sur le
sol le bienfait c'est quand elle se
mélange avec les minéraux mais
malheureusement on a pollué toul au sol
donc elle se mélange aussi avec des
pesticides les noms venant on a pu la
récupérer
avant ce stade là et on a fait beaucoup
de tests
on a fait des tests avec des
laboratoires on a fait analyser l'eau
dans le monde entier en australie en
chine en afrique
en guadeloupe les résultats étaient
absolument identique en fait l'amérique
hulot
les purs zéro nitrate zéro pesticide
c'est même très rassurant d'ailleurs
alors vous allez me dire
l'air est pollué on va polluer l'eau
mais à ce stade c'est la même chose dans
la condensation la molécule ne va pas se
mélanger avec la pollution qu'elle va
rencontrer dans l'air il va y avoir de
la pollution dans l'air mais elle va pas
se mélanger avec mais pour éviter ça on
a aussi mis des systèmes de filtration
très performant sur ces générateurs qui
vont filtrer l'air et qui vont aussi
filtrer l'eau alors qu'on en a pas pas
besoin parce qu'en fait on n'a pas
besoin de la dépolluer mais c'est que de
la sécurité on a voulu vraiment avoir un
produit vous n'avez aucun risque du
développement bactériologique autres à
l'intérieur de des générateurs elle
fonctionne à l'électricité mais on a su
les faire marcher avec des systèmes
solaires ou éoliens on a fabriqué des
générateurs qui vont de 38 jusqu'à dix
mille litres et on les a testés
en fait c'est une en tout cas pour les
grosses capacités c'est une vraie
solution pour les régions qui sont en
situation de pénurie d'eau je voudrais
revenir un petit peu maintenant sur ce
sac ça ça c'est la consommation d'eau en
deux personnes en guadeloupe pendant un
mois et on estime la consommation d'eau
de bouteilles en plastique sur une année
à plus 150 millions de bouteilles 1.5
million de fois ce sac les conséquences
sur nos îles sont beaucoup plus
dramatique
il faudrait absolument éviter ça et le
dernier petit conseil que je pourrais
donner une petite phrase qu'il faudrait
retenir c'est arrêtons de croire
arrêtons de boire de croître boire ce
qu'on nous dit excusez moi je vais faire
tuer
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]